* Quirlige Klänge *
Die Ecole Hoteliere de Lausanne
gehört zu den renommiertesten Han-
delsschulen für die Hotelindustrie.
2'800 Studenten aus über 110 Nationen
streben an der EHL nach Exzellenz,
Können und Selbstbewusstsein.
Wir begleiten drei Studenten
im Vorbereitungsjahr
und zwei am Ende ihres Studiums.
Alexandre Charlaix, 18 Jahre alt.
Mit seiner Matura in der Tasche
geht er in das Vorbereitungsjahr.
Emma Pittet ist 21,
geboren in der Genferseeregion.
Sie beginnt ihr Studium
an dieser internationalen Schule.
Genau wie Alexandre Attia,
19 Jahre alt.
Der Sohn eines Hoteliers geht mit
Selbstvertrauen ins erste Semester.
Annina von Falkenstein beginnt
mit 21 ihr vorletztes Studienjahr.
Die junge Baslerin strebt
nach nichts weniger als Exzellenz.
Afrim Beqa, 27,
startet sein letztes Semester.
Der energetische Afrim möchte
selbständiger Unternehmer werden.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Für Emma ist es der grosse Tag.
Wie alle, die im vorbereitenden Jahr
mit der EHL beginnen,
stellt sie sich darauf ein,
sechs Monate auf dem Campus
der Schule zu leben.
(Mann, französisch) Bringst du
Gepäck für sechs Monate mit?
Eigentlich kann ich
an den Wochenenden nach Hause,
aber ich dachte,
ich nehme einen kleinen Vorrat mit.
Die Anmeldung ist am Ende des Flurs.
Die Leute stehen nach Alphabet an.
Es gibt Schalter für jeden Namen.
Du bekommst deinen Schlüssel
und etwas Material.
Dann holst du hier deine Sachen,
und wir suchen dein Zimmer.
Perfekt, vielen Dank!
Fast 400 neue Schüler
kommen zweimal pro Jahr.
Bei jedem Eintrittstermin
ist die Schule in Aufruhr.
Nach langem Suchen
hat Emma ihren Weg gefunden.
Dieses Mal ist sie sich
ihrer Wahl sicher.
Emma, Sie haben das Zimmer 706,
Gebäude E.
Im Zimmer befinden sich
die Zimmer- und die Wäschekarte
mit bereits 10 Fr. Guthaben.
Sie können aufs Zimmer,
sobald Sie wollen.
Sie fragen Schüler
vor der Rezeption,
um Sie zu begleiten
und mit dem Gepäck zu helfen.
Weisst, du wo es ist?
(Englisch) Brauchst du Hilfe?
(Englisch) Wir wissen nicht,
wo mein Zimmer ist.
(Französisch) Du sprichst
Französisch, nehme ich an.
Also gehen wir, ich begleite euch.
Ich nehme den Koffer.
(Mutter) C'est gentil,
merci beaucoup.
Du wirst sehen,
du wirst viele Leute treffen,
die aus unterschiedlichen Welten
kommen,
Du wirst oft Schlange stehen,
aber es ist angenehm.
Auf dem Campus
gibt es gute Angebote.
Es hat Küchen zur Verfügung,
Restaurant, Bar.
Es ist wirklich toll. V.a.
für die Neulinge auf dem Campus.
Oh, das ist aber gross.
Ich habe es kleiner erwartet.
Sehr hübsch.
Perfekt.
(Mann) Was hältst du davon?
Ehrlich gesagt
ist es grösser als erwartet.
Ich bin erleichtert,
ich hatte ein wenig Angst.
Es ist sympathisch und
der Fitnessraum ist gleich unten -
praktisch!
Mais an fait ...
Ah, ein kleiner Kühlschrank!
"... ceremonie d'ouverture ..."
Das Tagesprogramm verrät:
An der EHL ist alles klar geregelt.
" ... controle du diplome,
les livres scolaire ... "
(Mann) Haben Sie auch
so eine Schule besucht?
Überhaupt nicht.
Ich war zuerst Krankenschwester.
Jetzt bin ich Psychologin,
in der Kinderpsychiatrie.
Ich bin nicht in der Welt
des Managements.
Ich bin auch im Service,
aber im Gesundheitsservice.
(Mutter) Die Schule bedeutet ein
wichtiges finanzielles Engagement.
Wir sehen es als Geschenk an
für Emma, das ihr einen Weg öffnet,
zu dem wir einen grossen Anteil
beitragen können.
Sie hat hart gearbeitet, um auch
selbst einen Teil beizusteuern.
Das ist
ein wirklich schönes Geschenk.
Du hast Freude daran und engagierst
dich wirklich sehr dafür.
Was zählt, ist die Motivation, auch
wenn man die Mittel dazu nicht hat.
Emma ist sehr motiviert.
Das Vorbereitungsjahr
kostet fast 40'000 Fr.
Auch Alex
studiert das Tagesprogramm.
Er hat sich
für diese Schule entschieden,
nachdem er das von der EHL
organisierte Sommercamp besucht hat.
(Französisch) Frühstück um 10 Uhr.
Obligatorisch.
Wir holen dein Arbeitsmaterial,
dein Messer-Set, deine Schulbücher.
So sind wir schneller. Du weisst,
du bist ein bisschen im Stress.
Auf geht's!
Dort ist der Foodcourt,
wo ich auch kochen werde.
Oben sind die Klassenzimmer.
Dort sind die Sushi-Bar und
weitere Verpflegungsmöglichkeiten.
Nicht die schönsten Schuhe, aber
wenigstens sind sie komfortabel.
In den ersten sechs Monaten
nehmen die Schüler
an vielen praktischen Workshops teil,
insbesondere an dem fürs Kochen.
Unpassend für eine Parade -
aber hinter dem Herd
sind sie obligatorisch.
Die passen perfekt.
Gut für mich.
Logischerweise
muss man alles ausziehen,
denn in der Küche
werden Sie nichts darunter tragen.
Sie werden es warm genug haben,
ohne T-Shirt und Jacke.
Sitzt.
Wenn Sie die Arme kreuzen,
soll das Hemd nicht zu eng sein
an den Schultern. Passt die Hose?
Sie sind, wie sie sind,
da kann ich nicht viel ändern.
Hauptsache,
Sie können sich gut darin bewegen.
* Lachen *
Marathon für die Neuen:
Anpassen der Serviceuniformen.
Alle müssen
die Kleiderordnung beachten.
Es sind Studierende
der Hochschule für Couture in Sierre,
die die Änderungen der Anzüge
und der Damenkostüme vornehmen,
die von einer Spezialfirma
geliefert worden sind.
Sie können zuerst die Hose
anprobieren, mit der Bluse drin.
Und danach schauen wir den Rest an.
Okay, danke schön.
* Stimmengewirr *
Sieht gut aus.
Können Sie sich bewegen?
Ja, perfekt.
Komfort und Eleganz
stehen auf dem Programm.
Bei den Frauen
dürfen die Ärmel der Bluse
die des Jacketts nicht überragen.
Würden Sie sich für die Hose
bitte umdrehen und mit den Fersen
auf das kleine Stück Holz stehen,
als ob Sie Absätze hätten.
Absatzhöhe 4 cm.
Hose 1 cm über dem Boden.
Knielanger Rock,
weder mehr noch weniger.
Mit seinen 19 Jahren scheint sich
Alexandre im Anzug wohlzufühlen.
Vielleicht, weil er an Luxushotels
gewöhnt ist? Sein Vater führt eines.
Die Ärmellänge.
Ich habe einen Anzug,
fünf Hemden, fünf weisse T-Shirts
und eine Hose erhalten.
Alle erhalten das Gleiche,
die gleiche Uniform,
die gleiche Krawattenfarbe, rot.
Alle haben die gleiche Uniform.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, und dir?
Ja, danke.
Hast du deinen Anzug geholt?
Ja, ich habe gerade alles geholt.
Hast du die Schuhe und die Schürze?
Ja. Ich habe alles geholt
und bin gerade dran, sie zu falten.
Ich werde dasselbe machen. Ich muss
noch meinen Koffer auspacken.
Ich bin in Hotels aufgewachsen,
Ich habe meinen Vater arbeiten
sehen, kenne das Hotelbusiness.
Es hat mich
schon immer fasziniert hat.
Das Werk meines Vaters
möchte ich fortführen.
Alexandre
ist sprichwörtlich gern am Ball,
er spielt Volleyball
auf Profiniveau.
Ich kann es kaum erwarten, in diese
Saison zu starten und zu sehen,
was sie mit sich bringt.
Hast du schon alles ausgepackt?
Ja, alles ausgepackt.
- Mach ich gleich auch noch.
Das Team ist meist
top 3 oder 4 der Schweiz.
Ich bin bereit,
diese Herausforderung anzunehmen.
Ich bin motiviert, meine sportlichen
und beruflichen Ziele zu verfolgen.
Es ist wird schwierig.
Jeden Tag Training.
Matches und Turniere am Wochenende.
Im Oktober oder November
gehen wir an die EM in Rumänien.
Ich werde evtl. ein, zwei Tage
nicht hier sein können.
Ein grosses Jahr mit viel Programm
erwartet mich, aber ich bin bereit.
Vor zwei Jahren war ich
auf der Sportschule Lausanne,
dort gab es wirklich kleine Betten.
Ich hatte Angst,
diese Betten würden auch klein sein,
aber sie sind gemütlich und breit.
Momentan verstehen wir uns gut.
Ich lege
die beiden neuen Krawatten dazu,
die wir
von der Schule erhalten haben.
Für Neuankömmlinge
ist es oft nicht selbstverständlich,
ein Zimmer für sechs Monate
mit einem Studenten zu teilen,
den sie kaum kennen,
aber es gehört zum Campusleben.
(Mann) Lebst du zum ersten Mal
weit weg von zu Hause?
Ja, ohne meinen Bruder,
das ist sehr beunruhigend,
aber mal sehen, wie's wird.
Es ist aufregend, ein wenig un-
heimlich. Das gehört zum Abenteuer.
Dann wirst du lernen müssen,
dich zu organisieren.
Er ist ein bisschen unordentlich.
- Überhaupt nicht!
Das wird hier nicht so sein. Ich bin
allein und muss selber schauen.
(Mann) Waren Sie auch
an so einer Schule?
Nein, ich war auf einer Kunstschule.
Mit dem hier
kann ich nichts anfangen.
Ich war Stylistin, also überhaupt
nicht im gleichen Bereich.
Ich hätte das ursprünglich
auch tun sollen.
Programmänderung. Wir werden uns
an die Umstände anpassen müssen.
Afrim, 27, kam vor dreieinhalb Jahren
an die EHL.
Heute beginnt sein letztes Semester.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
ob ich froh bin, fertig zu sein
oder traurig, zu gehen.
Wir werden sehen.
Der Foodcourt: Hier essen
und arbeiten wir auch
und treffen uns in der Gruppe.
Es stärkt den Zusammenhalt
und den Teamgeist,
wenn man sich täglich begegnet.
Sobald man sich nicht so oft sieht,
geht der Teamgeist verloren,
und man will dann
schnellstmöglich wieder hierher.
Ich bin sehr froh,
wieder zurückzukommen.
Heute hatte ich den ersten Kurs
in Unternehmertum.
Das war sehr interessant.
Morgen habe ich
den zweiten Kurs in Innovation.
Im letzten Semester
ist es ein wenig speziell,
denn wir haben drei,
die wir frei wählen können.
Ich besuche Unternehmertum,
Innovation und einen dritten Kurs,
der mehr der Hotellerie entspricht.
Er heisst
Management mit optimaler Wirkung.
Ich hatte diesen Kurs noch nicht,
er wird eine Woche dauern,
jeden Tag von 8 - 18 Uhr,
also sehr intensiv.
Und für die zwei andern Workshops
sind es zwei Kurse pro Woche,
während vier Wochen.
Management, Unternehmertum.
Das Vorbereitungsjahr
und die vielen Workshops
scheinen weit weg für Afrim.
Aber er behält gute Erinnerungen
an diese praktischen Ausbildungen.
Guten Tag, Chef. Wir machen
einen kurzen Rundgang in der Küche.
Hier ist die warme Küche,
alle warmen Speisen
werden hier zubereitet.
Die kalten Vorspeisen und Gerichte
dort hinten.
Alles was Bankett ist, wird in einer
anderen Abteilung organisiert.
Hinten rechts ist die Gourmetküche.
Dort ist die Bäckerei.
Alles Brot wird hier hergestellt.
Hallo, Chef.
Alles Brot, Croissants und Süssback-
waren werden direkt hier hergestellt
und an der Schule verkauft.
In diesem Workshop
verbringt man gerne Zeit,
allerdings muss man dafür
früh aufstehen,
aber ist es sehr interessant.
Hier waren wir für eine Woche.
Foodcourt-Produktion
hatten wir drei- oder viermal
während vier Wochen.
Die meisten Workshops
dauern aber eine Woche lang.
Das hier war mein Lieblings-Workshop
im Vorbereitungsjahr.
Die Wiege der Sinne, so heisst
das Gourmetrestaurant der Schule.
Ich weiss nicht, ob Sie
schon die Möglichkeit hatten,
hierherzukommen.
Das ist das Spitzenrestaurant der
Schule, das 80 Gäste empfangen kann.
Es ist wirklich genial,
man hat als Schüler die Möglichkeit,
Gourmetküche zu degustieren
und zu essen.
Mit der Schülerkarte kann man direkt
hier bezahlen, mit 20 % Rabatt,
dann ist es nicht mehr so teuer.
Wir haben das Glück,
die besten Fachkräfte aus Frankreich
hier zu haben,
die kochen und uns coachen.
Wir haben hier also
die allerbesten Lehrer.
* Lockere Musik *
Annina, 21, hat gerade ihr vorletztes
Semester begonnen, mit dem Ehrgeiz,
zehn von zehn Exzellenz-Punkten
zu erreichen.
Vielseitig engagiert, übernimmt sie
zusätzlich zu den Kursen
Verantwortung beim Buddy-Programm,
bei dem das Patronat
über einen Neuling übernommen wird.
Sie nutzt ihre Mittagspause,
um Maeva zu treffen,
die Juniorin, deren Patin sie ist.
(Französisch) Bist du
im fünften Bachelorsemester?
Ja, das ist mein letztes Jahr,
ich bin bald fertig,
aber es gibt
noch einiges zu erledigen.
Weisst du,
wo du dann später hinwillst?
Ich habe gerade
die Human Resources entdeckt,
Personaldienst, das gefällt mir.
Würdest du gerne
in die Hotelbranche einsteigen
oder etwas völlig anderes machen?
Ich würde gerne
in der Hotellerie bleiben,
wenigstens für ein paar Jahre.
Wenn ich genug davon habe,
kann ich ja etwas anderes machen.
Und du, weisst du es schon?
Das Buddy-Programm
ist eine Möglichkeit,
ihre Fähigkeiten in der Betreuung
und in der Hotellerie zu üben,
den beiden Leidenschaften
der jungen Baslerin.
Ich finde das System gut.
Das Netzwerk der Ehemaligen
ist etwas Wichtiges für die Schule.
Schon im Vorbereitungsjahr lernt man
die Leute aus den höheren Jahrgängen
und die Bachelorstudenten kennen.
Hast du viele Leute kennengelernt,
die an die EHL sind?
Ja, während meiner zwei Wochen
im Beau Rivage in Lausanne.
Cafeteria, Fingerfood, Sushi-Bar
oder Gourmet-Restaurant -
um sich zu ernähren, haben
die Studenten die Qual der Wahl.
Alles eine Frage des Budgets.
Ich bin in der Schweiz geboren
und aufgewachsen,
stamme aber ursprünglich
aus dem Kosovo.
Ich bin Sohn von Immigranten,
die 1988 hierhergezogen sind.
Es gibt an der Schule nicht nur Kin-
der aus wohlhabenden Verhältnissen
mit einem einfachen
und angenehmen Leben.
Meine Eltern z.B.
waren politische Flüchtlinge,
die nicht viel mitbrachten.
Wir wohnten in einem
als schwierig bekannten Quartier.
Sie mussten hart arbeiten
und zeigten mir,
wie man mit Motivation
etwas erreichen kann.
Ich habe mich untypischerweise
anstatt fürs Gymnasium
für eine Lehre entschieden,
da ich aktiv sein
und schneller ins Arbeitsleben
eintauchen wollte.
Ich machte eine vierjährige Lehre
als Mechaniker.
Ich bin mit 23 Jahren
hierhergekommen.
Ich habe das Vorbereitungsjahr
sechs Monate hier
und sechs Monate
in Thailand absolviert.
Das ist auch ein Grund,
warum ich die EHL machen wollte.
So war es möglich, während der
akademischen Ausbildung zu reisen.
Mein Wunsch ist es,
ein Restaurant zu eröffnen.
Wir versuchen gerade,
über den Ort zu verhandeln.
Wir kennen das genaue Datum noch
nicht, die Verhandlungen laufen
und wir werden bald
einen Gesprächstermin fixieren.
* Lockere Musik *
Für Emma und ihre Kollegen
geht es mit der Begrüssungsrede
des Direktors
der Hotelfachschule Lausanne weiter.
Weil die englische und die
französische Sektion zusammen sind,
wählt Michel Rochat
Shakespeares Sprache.
(Mann) Liebe neue Studenten.
Nicht Sie haben die EHL gewählt,
wir haben Sie gewählt.
Als top Hospitality Universität
sind wir direkt verbunden
mit den besten Firmen
im Gastgewerbe.
Liebe neue Studenten.
Das Studentenleben
ist sehr anspruchsvoll.
Erlauben Sie mir, Ihnen die
drei einfachen Schlüssel zu geben,
die für mich
die Basis des Erfolgs darstellen:
Arbeit ...
... Arbeit ...
... und Arbeit.
Danke und willkommen
in der EHL-Familie!
Die EHL-Familie ist die erste Einheit
in einem viel grösseren Ganzen.
Denn hier ist Vernetzung
ein Kernbegriff.
* Beschwingter Popsong
"Toxic" von Britney Spears *
# I'm addicted to you,
don't you know that you're toxic?"
Endlich der Aperitif,
wo die Neuen und ihre Eltern
einen Vorgeschmack
in Sachen Exzellenz bekommen.
* Lockere Klaviermusik *
* Süffisanter Gesang *
Sie hatte sich
für Medizin eingeschrieben,
dann wollte sie Kunstgeschichte
studieren und plötzlich bekam sie
diese Leidenschaft für das
Eventmanagement und die Hotellerie,
und wir haben sie
auf diesem Weg begleitet.
Ich habe ihr schon immer gesagt:
"Das Wichtigste ist es,
das zu machen, was man liebt."
Sie hat es sich ausgesucht,
ich vertraue ihr.
Ich denke, es ist eine tolle Wahl.
Es ist ein bisschen
eine "Wir sind die Besten"-Schule.
Ich glaube aber, dass meine Tochter
kritisch und klarsichtig
bleiben wird über dieses
"Wir sind die Besten".
Auf Wiedersehen, Eltern.
Hallo, Monsieur Laurent.
Das Auge der EHL, der grosse Wächter
über die Kleiderordnung
und das gute Benehmen.
* Stimmengewirr *
(Englisch) Ich kenne Sie nicht,
aber wenn ich Ihre Gesichter sehe,
Ihre Haltung, Ihr Lächeln,
die Art wie Sie sich anziehen
und wie Sie mich anschauen,
dann habe ich
eine recht gute Einschätzung
Ihrer mentalen Einstellung.
Die Kleiderordnung besagt nicht,
dass jeder dunkelblau
oder schwarz tragen soll.
Wenn ich Sie anschaue, sind Sie
fast alle in einer Uniform.
Aber wenn Sie so weit gehen wollen,
geht das nicht.
Zuerst entfalten Sie die Krawatte
komplett.
Bitte nicht so aufhängen,
so bricht die Seide.
Die Idee ist, sie aufzurollen,
und sie flach zu halten.
Und bitte: Niemand in diesem Raum
zieht sie so an und aus,
ohne den Knoten zu lösen.
Nein, jeden Abend lösen und
morgens einen neuen Knoten machen.
Sie gehen in die Patisserie,
die Bäckerei, zum Housekeeping  -
und es muss perfekt sein.
Willkommen in der Welt des Bügelns -
für einige von Ihnen.
Diese Frage
stellen Sie sich jeden Morgen:
Stimmte heute
meine professionelle Erscheinung
mit den Werten der EHL überein?
Ich werde Sie nicht anschreien
und ins Zimmer zurückschicken.
Nein, nein.
Wir machen das sehr professionell.
Sie erhalten von mir
eine kleine Karte:
"Heute stimmt
Ihr professioneller Auftritt
nicht überein
mit den Werten der EHL."
Sie erhalten diese Karte.
Das ist nur der Anfang.
* Vereinzelte Lacher *
Denn wenn ich Ihnen
diese Karte gebe, bitte ich Sie,
Ihren EHL-Badge auszuhändigen.
Wenn Sie diesen auf dem Campus
nicht bei sich tragen, sind Sie tot.
Sie können sich nicht bewegen,
nicht essen, nicht drucken.
Sie können nichts mehr tun.
Und der Badge ist in meiner Tasche.
Halten Sie den Dresscode nicht ein,
nehme ich Ihnen den Badge weg
und gebe Ihnen 2 Std.,
um sich umzuziehen.
Auf dem Campus
werden Sie beobachtet.
Viele Leute beobachten Sie.
Die ganze Zeit.
* Applaus *
(Alex) Sie wollen, dass jeder
sich selbst, ein Original ist
und trotz des Dresscodes
seinen eigenen Stil behält.
Das scheint aber sehr paradox,
da wir alle dasselbe tragen.
Wir werden sehen,
wie sich das Ganze abspielt.
Momentan stört es mich
noch nicht, wie ich bin
und ein wenig Lockerheit in meiner
Kleidung schadet sicher nicht.
Das Einzige, was ich behalten kann,
sind meine Haare,
also warum nicht davon profitieren?
Aber wenn mir dann gesagt wird,
dass mein Namensschild schief hängt,
dann finde ich das
einfach übertrieben.
Das ist
der klassische Krawattenknoten,
der uns empfohlen wurde und den wir
das ganze Jahr so machen.
Letztes Jahr, als ich auf dem Campus
war, musste ich ihn lernen,
inzwischen habe ich ihn verlernt,
da ich nicht das ganze Jahr
so etwas trage.
Ich trage sonst eher
grosse Pullover und T-Shirts.
(Mann) Und deine Armbänder?
Ich werde sie wohl ausziehen müssen,
das tut weh.
Fertig.
Annina ist auch Botschafterin
der Schule.
Sie bereitet sich
auf ihre nächste Mission vor:
Auf einer Messe in Paris
wird sie interessierten Studenten
den Lehrplan der EHL erläutern.
Entschuldige die Verspätung.
Alors, je vais prendre place.
- Absolument.
Hattest du einen schönen Tag?
- Ja. Einen langen Tag.
Dein Auftrag wird sein,
die anderen Studenten aufzuklären,
die möglicherweise
an der EHL interessiert sind.
Wir schauen zwei, drei Sachen an,
die du wissen musst,
um Auskunft zu geben. Wir beginnen
mit dem Bachelor-Programm.
Ich denke, du kennst es bereits.
Also, ich weiss mehr oder weniger,
was in den Semesterplänen steht.
Kannst du mir diese Präsentation
später zusenden?
Kann ich machen, wenn du willst.
Gut, dann muss ich mir
keine Notizen machen.
Du kannst auf dem Forum
deine Informationen
über die Schule aufzählen.
1893 gegründet, etwas mehr
als 2'700 eingetragene Schüler,
inbegriffen diejenigen,
die ein Praktikum machen.
Februar und September
beginnt jeweils die Schule,
ca. 114 Nationalitäten
auf dem Campus.
Zwei Drittel englisch-, ein Drittel
französischsprachig, zwei Sektionen.
Wir haben über 30 Komitees.
Du kannst vom Schülerleben,
von den verschiedenen Events,
bei denen du mitgemacht hast,
erzählen.
Ob du an Events teilgenommen hast
als Komiteemitglied
und in der Organisation.
Und wir haben ein sehr
grosses Netzwerk von Ehemaligen.
Um diese Einführungswoche
zu beenden,
gibt es nichts Besseres
als eine kleine Party.
Auf dem Programm steht die
Schatzsuche, ein Einweihungsritual,
das Teamgeist wecken soll,
Teambuilding, wie sie hier sagen.
* Kreischen *
* Lockere Musik, Stimmengewirr *
(Englisch)
(Alle) EHL! EHL! EHL!
* Jubel *
* Lockere Musik *
Ich packe meinen Koffer für Paris.
Ich gehe an die Messe
der grossen Handelsschulen
und vertrete dort die EHL.
Wir haben dort einen Stand,
um noch mehr Studenten anzuwerben,
um den Ruf unserer Schule zu stärken
und um internationale Präsenz
zu zeigen.
(Mann) Verdienst du etwas dabei?
Ich erhalte pro Stunde 10 Fr.
auf meine Essenskarte,
mit der wir Essen und Getränke
oder Schokolade in der Boutique
kaufen können.
Für mich ist das gut so,
denn ich mache es auch,
weil ich die Schule mag,
die ich gewählt habe,
und grosses Glück habe,
die EHL absolvieren zu können.
Und weil ich gerne
meine Erfahrungen teile.
* Sirene *
Paris, Messe der grossen
Handels- und Ingenieursschulen.
Wir beginnen
mit diesem Vorbereitungsjahr.
Es gibt Küchen-
und Service-Workshops.
Wir müssen dann auch
die Zimmer der anderen machen.
Arbeit an der Rezeption,
ein bisschen Weinkunde.
Nach diesen fünf Monaten
macht ihr ein erstes Praktikum
in einem Hotel irgendwo auf der
Welt, ihr werdet also reisen können.
Findet man danach leicht Arbeit?
- Ja, ziemlich leicht.
Sechs Monate nach dem Diplom
finden 96 % der Diplomierten eine
feste Anstellung, also sehr viele.
Und was kostet es?
Für die vier Jahre
kostet es total 155'000 Fr.
Suisses?
- Francs suisses, oui.
Okay.
155'000 Fr.
Die Schweizer sind privilegiert,
weil die EHL eine Vereinbarung mit
der Fachhochschule Westschweiz hat:
Sie zahlen die Hälfte,
also 76'000 Fr.
Emma ist im Morgengrauen aufgewacht
und geht sicheren Schrittes
zu ihrem ersten Workshop
in den Schulküchen.
Guten Tag.
- (Mann) Guten Tag.
Ist hier die Gourmeklasse?
- (Mann) Die Gourmetklasse? Ja.
* Klopfen *
Ich weiss nicht,
wie man das anzieht.
So?
(Mann) Was hast du denn
für eine Frisur?
Eine Art Donut,
der mich 20 Min. gekostet hat.
Ich dachte, es wäre obligatorisch,
denn auf dem kleinen Foto
hatte das Mädchen diese Frisur.
Also habe ich sie auch gemacht.
Wenigstens hält sie.
(Mann) Kommt alle hierher!
Um 7 Uhr seid ihr alle bereit.
Genau, und das Armband weg,
Knöpfe zu.
Könntest du mir kurz helfen?
- Darf man keine Kette tragen?
Nur keine Armbänder.
Gut so?
* Stimmengewirr, Lachen *
Für die nächsten Tage
sollt ihr um 7 Uhr bereit sein.
Es ist jetzt 7.06 Uhr. Es ist
eure erste Woche in der Küche?
(Alle) Ja, Chef.
Gewöhnt euch daran,
um 7 Uhr bereit zu sein. Okay?
Emma und ihre Kollegen
werden von A bis Z alles herstellen,
was 3 Std. später im Gourmetshop
des Campus verkauft wird,
einem Take-away-Service.
Bei Afrim herrscht
ein anderer Rhythmus vor.
In seinem kleinen Lausanner Studio
scheinen die Campus-Doppelzimmer
weit weg.
Mein kleines Zuhause.
Hier sind Dali,
James Dean und Batman.
Bis ich meinen ersten Picasso
aufhänge.
* Er lacht. *
Jetzt beginnt das letzte Semester.
Und mit ihm kommt das berühmte
Studenten-Business-Projekt,
das alle Schüler erwartet.
Wir sind ein Unternehmen,
welches Schülergruppen einstellt,
um ein neunwöchiges Consulting
für ein Projekt zu machen.
Marketing, Finanzen,
Portefeuille etc.
Wir werden sehen, wie das abläuft.
Das SBP,
das Studenten-Business-Projekt,
ist die letzte Prüfung
vor dem Bachelor-Abschluss.
Bleibt, ein motivierendes,
interessantes Projekt zu finden,
und es ebenso gut einzufädeln
wie die Krawatte.
Beim Krawattenbinden
habe ich ein kleines Geheimnis:
Ich öffne die Knoten nie,
so verliere ich morgens keine Zeit.
Alles ist bereit, ich weiss:
Die Form stimmt.
Ich trage gerne Anzüge. Es ist
eine Art Uniform an der Schule,
trotzdem hat jeder ein bisschen
Freiheit in seiner Kleiderwahl
und kann seinen eigenen Stil
einfliessen lassen,
das finde ich ziemlich cool.
Ich mag diese Art von Krawatten,
keine Ahnung, wie man die nennt,
vielleicht Sockenkrawatten,
wie auch immer.
Auch die Manschettenknöpfe sehen
sehr elegant und professionell aus.
Auch hier hat man eine gewisse
Freiheit in der Wahl der Knöpfe,
von denen ich sehr viele besitze.
Um Geld zu sparen kaufe ich sie
in China bei AliExpress.
* Lockere Musik *
(Alexandre) Wo sieht man sich
um 11 Uhr?
Da hinten, wo uns die Klienten
nicht sehen. Ihr Namensschild fehlt.
Muss ich es suchen gehen?
- Auf jeden Fall, holen Sie es!
Ich komme gleich,
ich muss zum Zimmer rennen.
Der erste Bankettworkshop
für einen Alexandre,
der heute Morgen
nicht wirklich glücklich ist.
In diesem Tempel des Gastgewerbes
ist jede Abweichung von den Regeln
und der Kleiderordnung inakzeptabel.
Wenn man mehr als 15 Min. zu spät
ist, wird man nicht zugelassen,
und man erhält einen Punkteabzug
bei der Wochennote von 6.
Ich habe jetzt schon eine Fünf,
was die Chance zu bestehen,
deutlich verkleinert.
Wir haben noch 15 Min. Zeit.
Gestern gab es zwei
mit 20 Min. Verspätung.
Sie mussten den Tag abbrechen
und erhielten einen Minuspunkt.
Es gibt keine Ausreden.
Ich musste heute Morgen
mein Hemd bügeln, nachschauen,
ob es keine Flecken hat
auf dem Anzug, hinten und vorne.
(Mann) Wer hat dir beigebracht,
dein Hemd zu bügeln?
Das war mein Vater vor drei,
vier Jahren. Das lernt man schnell.
Ich habe nur den vorderen Teil
des Hemdes gebügelt,
da ich den Anzug
sowieso nie ausziehe.
Alles klar?
Nehmt eure Armbänder ab!
Keine Ringe.
Den kleinen Knopf hier oben
schliessen.
Schwarze Socken. Okay.
Okay, sind alle anwesend?
Elisa? Alexandre? Theo? Marie?
Wir sind vollständig.
Der Stuhl bleibt hier,
das hindert uns nicht,
schon mit der Arbeit zu beginnen.
Eine der Besonderheiten der Schule
besteht darin,
die Schüler in eine reale Situation
zu versetzen.
Morgen kommen 260 Schüler
der ETH Lausanne.
Sie werden in der Aula lernen,
in den Pausen werden sie hier
Kaffee und Tee trinken.
Die Süsswaren hier in der Mitte,
Brot, Servietten und Brottellerchen.
Zitrone und Zucker kommen morgen.
Und vier Cocktailtische hier,
mit Abfalleimern und -säcken.
Alles klar? - Perfekt.
Hast du so etwas im Hotel
deines Vaters auch schon gemacht?
Nein, ich habe nie in den Hotels
meines Vaters gearbeitet.
Ich mag es nicht,
wenn die Leute wissen,
dass ich der Sohn des Direktors bin.
Es ist anders, in einem
unabhängigen Hotel zu arbeiten.
Ich habe einige Male geschnuppert,
Bankettvorbereitungen gemacht.
Im Dreieck, so.
Habt ihr's?
- (Frau) Non.
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
Konzentriert euch!
* Stimmengewirr, Lachen *
Macht einen Fächer!
Afrim wird heute das Thema seines
Studenten-Business-Projekts erfahren.
Wir hören gleich,
um welches Thema es in unserem neun
Wochen dauernden Projekt gehen wird.
Wir werden sehen, wie es läuft.
Es ist das letzte Projekt der EHL,
das ist aufregend.
Das ist mein Team.
Das Ziel im Team ist es,
verschiedene Kompetenzen zu bündeln,
um möglichst
effizient arbeiten zu können.
In neun Wochen
werden wir sagen können,
ob wir uns noch vertragen
und wie es so geht.
Ich spüre den Druck.
Afrim und sein Team erfahren gleich,
von welchem der 39 Partnerunternehmen
sie ausgewählt worden sind.
Eine entscheidende Wahl: zweieinhalb
Monate Arbeit, ein Diplom,
sogar eine besondere Erwähnung
in Aussicht, der Einsatz ist hoch.
* Rhythmische Schlagzeugmusik *
Die wunderbare Welt der Arbeit.
Zum ersten Mal reibt sich Alex daran.
C'est la meme chose.
Ich glaube, sie zahlt separat.
(Englisch) Ah, Sie zahlen separat.
Entschuldigung.
Tu peux la demander,
si elle veut le ticket.
Möchten Sie eine Quittung?
Nein? Okay.
Das dauert ein wenig lange.
Entschuldigung.
- Kein Problem.
Meine Haare? Ja, ich musste sie
schneiden. Am Samstag.
Seitlich max. 7 mm
und oben 5 cm.
Vorher hatte ich oben 15 cm.
Also musste ich zum Friseur,
ziemlich mies.
Kein Vergnügen,
die Haare fallen zu sehen.
Aber es ist nur für sechs Monate,
das geht.
* Pulsierende Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Il parait qu'on nous a pris
notre project.
Afrim und sein Team möchten gerne
an der Organisation der Olympischen
Jugendspiele teilnehmen,
die für 2020 in Lausanne
geplant sind.
Aber sie sind nicht die einzigen ...
Ein Team jubelt.
* Stimmengewirr *
Aber es ist nicht das von Afrim.
Bon, mais ca sera bien, ca va.
Ja, es ist nicht sehr cool,
aber es wird schon gut sein.
Auch wenn wir nicht unser
Lieblingsthema erhalten haben,
sind wir trotzdem zufrieden.
Wir werden
unsere Motivation steigern.
Afrim und seine Gruppe
haben nur ihre dritte Wahl erhalten,
aber sie lassen sich
nicht entmutigen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nächstes Mal in der Hotelfachschule:
Wenn er sich konzentriert,
arbeitet er sehr gut.
Er lässt sich schnell ablenken und
spielt dann mit seinen Kameraden.
Meine Kameraden
wollen mit mir spielen.
* Sie sprechen Französisch. *
A la six.
Bewahren Sie Ihre tolle Energie,
sehr gut,
aber organisieren Sie sich
etwas besser.
Was für ein Spass!
Acht, neun, zehn ...
funktioniert tatsächlich.
Ich weiss, man muss es gut machen,
aber mit etwas Humor
ginge es besser.
Manchmal macht es mich
ein wenig traurig.
Wenn ich zu Hause in Basel bin,
denke ich:
"Mein Leben in Basel
werde ich vermissen."
Wenn ich mit der Schule fertig bin,
werde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr nach Hause zurückkommen.
(Frau) Siehst du eine andere Option?
- Wir haben bis jetzt keine gesehen.
Ja, wir haben
noch einiges zu erledigen.
Wir werden sehen,
wie wir das machen.
Ich muss los,
in einer Dreiviertelstunde.